[Music]
do
so
[Music]
hello hello am i on i'm not on nobody
can hear
me hello
doesn't sound like i'm on hi hello hello
am i good
can you guys hear me oh there we are
sorry i was a little late getting up
here there are just so many
wonderful people here tonight that i
just had to say hi to
most of them if i haven't said hi to you
yet so far i will get to you don't worry
my name is karen welcome to the table
i am so glad you're here if you're here
in the sanctuary or if you're watching
online welcome you've picked a great
great night to join us
i have a couple of announcements before
we get started uh
first of all happy pride
happy pride we are wrapping up pride
month this is the last sunday of pride
month
uh but i like to think of it as just the
warm-up for the rest of the year
there is no you know we we don't we
don't contain pride to just one month
it's all year long so welcome and we're
so glad you're here
um second announcement is more like
three and one so just remember you have
three things to remember
so i might quiz you at the end of the
service
it's all all uh related to the fourth of
july
so first off next sunday is the fourth
of july
and so we will not be having our five
o'clock service
we are going to join with pleasant
valley united methodist church
they're the congregation that meets
right here at 11 a.m on sunday mornings
so they're basically their extended
family to us at the table
so we are going to join with them so
please
join us 11 a.m next sunday we will not
be here at 5 00 p.m
if you show up i'm sorry we won't be
here
so you want to make sure to come at 11
a.m secondly
uh let's see oh uh
also pleasant valley has invited us to
join them
for their fireworks uh on
saturday so this next this coming
saturday which is july
3rd they've invited us at 6 30 p.m to
meet in their parking lot they're going
to watch
the city of saxi fireworks and there's a
great view apparently from their parking
lot
they're going to have a bounce house a
dj live music
free hot dogs games so it's going to be
super fun and a great way to celebrate
the fourth and it's all free
so another opportunity to gather with
our extended family of pleasant valley
and be a part of the festivities and
then lastly
we've been doing first sunday dinner
gatherings
over at hat creek burger company in saxi
again the first sunday is 4th of july
but we still want to get together and
eat and be together so we're going to do
that
the second sunday which is the 11th are
you guys
are you tracking so what was the what
was the first one
11 a.m on sunday good job matthew second
[Music]
what's saturday fireworks what time
6 30. bounce house free hot dogs
and then what's the third thing
you guys are good good job
and you know i've just got to say this
for those that think that nobody listens
to announcements
people listen so thank you
all right we've got some great worship
so why don't we pray
and then we'll transition to some music
and worshiping god
[Music]
god thank you so much for tonight thank
you for your presence with us
that is not just limited to this
building but god i'm so thankful that
your presence goes with us wherever we
go
god your love goes with us wherever we
your grace goes with us wherever we go
your forgiveness
your mercy god thank you for that
thank you that we can't escape it and i
and i don't say that in like a
threatening
way it's so good your love is so good
so god help us to experience that
tonight through
the songs we're about to sing together
through the community that's here
and online through the message that
we're going to hear from maggie
god let it just point us to you
continually
and god i pray that each person who's
listening tonight
gets something from you god that is so
personal
so personal to each one that's
undeniably you god
and undeniably your goodness so i pray
that we would have
open hearts to receive whatever it is
you have for us tonight god and i thank
you in advance for that
in jesus name i pray amen
thank you karen that is um
such what you said at the beginning of
that prayer
just resonated so much with what i was
feeling as we're going into this worship
set
because i feel like sometimes we just
have a tendency to
over i have a tendency to over
complicate things you know like
in faith it's easy like reading the
bible can be complicated trying to
interpret it realizing we bring filters
to our faith
and our upbringing and our experiences
our history
but at the end of the day if i can just
believe
that i was created by a god
who loves me and that love is is the
thing that
sparked our life our breath it's the
thing that sustains us
when i connect with that it's that
simple you know like
that's uh what worship is for me as well
it's just
a chance to connect with that spark that
divine
love that i believe we were each created
with from our first breath
before our first breath from conception
you were made
uniquely by a god who loves you and
that's
what we're coming here to do tonight is
just connect with that
love and so we can we can figure out the
rest
you know other times but i hope that
during this worship set tonight
we can simplify it just a little bit and
remember
that there is a burning love that you
were created with
and i hope that we can connect with that
love together
all right this is my sister melody this
is tyler
this is caitlin and noel they're up here
with me and
we're all in this together so can you
guys stand with us
it's not a show it's just a chance for
us to connect
so please sing out if you want to
involve
all senses of your body i encourage you
use your hands
use your feet um because he made them
all all right
so everything's everything's welcome
[Music]
your love is
like radiant diamonds
bursting inside us
we cannot contain
when your love will
surely come find us
like blazing wildfires
[Music]
and made it
your love is
like radiant diamonds
bursting inside
[Music]
surely come find us
like blazing wildfires
sing in your name here we go
[Music]
to your designs
these
be multiplied
all right here we go we're going to do a
little hallelujah can you sing this with
me
oh hallelujah hallelujah
hallelujah sing hallelujah
hallelujah hallelujah
hallelujah
[Music]
stretch
[Applause]
[Music]
to your
stretch across
[Music]
these
hallelujah hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah sing hallelujah
hallelujah hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
in my mother's womb
you form me with your hands
[Music]
you're an artist and a potter
i'm the canvas
[Music]
for your glory
and for your name
there's a healing light
just beyond the clouds fire
and i see clearly now and i know
nothing has been wasted
no failure or mistake
you're an artist and a potter
on the canvas and the clay
and you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my goodness
work together
for your glory
and for your name and you make
all things work together
for my future
and for my goodie you make all these
work together
for your glory
and for your name
and i doubt it lord remind me
i'm wonderfully made
you're an artist and a potter
i'm the candice in the great and i know
nothing has been wasted no
failure or mistake you're an
artist and a potter on the canvas say
that again
let it be true for you
[Music]
and i know nothing has been wasted
no failure or mistake
you're an artist and a potter
i'm the canvas let's sing that again
when i doubt it lord remind me
i'm a wonderfully maid you're an
artist and a partner i'm the canvas
in the clay and i know nothing
has been wasted no failure
or mistake you're an artist
and a partner on the campus
work together
for my future
and for my good you make
all these
[Music]
all things work together for you
your love sets a story right
here he writes the story
[Music]
you're not finished with me
you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with say that again
you're not finished with me
you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with
[Music]
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me
[Music]
thank you god
that you see us in full in whole
not just the good moments
you see it all
and you work it together in love
in grace and goodness you work it
together
to bring about beauty our most
painful moments god our deepest regrets
you are there in the midst of those
and you work it together to create
something beautiful
god we bring our shame to you the pieces
that don't feel quite good enough
and we lay them down trusting that you
can create something beautiful even
from our mess even from our brokenness
our ugliness our shame and our sin god
you use it all you take it all
thank you for continuing to write the
story for us
we're going to move into our prayer of
the people and if this is your first
time with us
um this is a tradition that's been
passed down through christian history
and what's going to happen is i'm going
to start with a short prayer
and at the end of each line you'll see
words up on the screen that are in red
and we can all say those together
and join in and at the end of that short
prayer i'm gonna open up some space and
some time
for us to lift um
people or situations that you're
carrying on your heart
up to god together and just make some
room for us to carry those
together and instead of it just being
something that you're carrying
individually on your own
it's just a time for us to lift those
people up before god
as a community believing that he
cares and he loves them and he wants to
continue writing their
story he wants to continue transforming
and showing up for them
just as he does for us so i encourage
you guys to enter into this space with
us
um you're all welcome even those of you
who are joining us online
karen will be watching our live stream
and if you want to write a prayer
request into the comments
we just ask that you keep it to just
someone's name instead of giving
any information that would be private to
them but
please join in by sharing those requests
and karen will read them out so that we
can all participate in this together
i'm gonna start
[Music]
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community
and all of those who live in them we
pray to you
and jesus for the good earth that you
have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you
for those who travel on land sea and air
we pray to you for the old
and the sick for the widow and the
orphan
for the injured and suffering we pray to
you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so now we lift these names and
situations
up to you
[Music]
and justice
from online anna marie and peace
for those in florida
[Music]
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that you may
give them life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
foreign
you have been so so good
to me
i took a breath you breathe your life
in me
you have been so so good
[Music]
reckless
i don't deserve it still you
give yourself away
oh the overwhelming
never ending
of reckless
[Music]
we believe in jesus
still your love for me
[Music]
you have been so so kind to me
when i fell no worth you
paid it off me
thank you jesus
you have been so so kind to me
oh the overwhelming never ending
[Music]
reckless
there's no shadow you won't light up
mountain you won't climb up coming
[Music]
no shadow
won't tear down coming after me
[Music]
light up
i won't tear down
[Music]
i don't deserve it still you
give yourself away
love god
[Music]
jesus thank you for a love that does not
give up
that pursues us
a love that rescues us
a love that sees each one of us
uniquely and individually
thank you that it's not about what we do
to earn it
it's already there we were created in it
[Music]
god would we connect with that love even
as we leave this place tonight and would
we take it into this world would we take
it into our families into our
relationships
into our homes and our workplaces and
our schools
god would we be a transforming love of
jesus on this earth
[Music]
thank you for your goodness and your
kindness that meets us right where we're
at
would you open our hearts to hear from
you tonight and to receive everything
that you would have for us god
thank you for this time together we are
so appreciative it's such a gift
thank you god amen
guys thanks so much you can go ahead and
be seated and
as you are go ahead and turn and um wave
to the people around you say hello
and then the amazing brett tilford will
take over
well good evening everyone yeah i know
we're we're kind of still doing the um
you know turn
and like wave thing i know um maybe one
day
well for to the chagrin of all the
introverts who kind of probably like
that i'm glad we don't have to do
giant bear hugs from random people you
know
some people don't aren't in for that but
um someday we'll
reinstitute bear hugs um well
uh like uh mindy mentioned my name's
brett i'm the pastor here
yes the church does have a pastor i have
been um playing hooky for like four
weeks so i have not been here on sundays
for quite a while
i'm just taking just taking a break and
um i'll probably share more um probably
not next week because will be that joint
service with pleasant valley but maybe
the sunday after that
a little bit more of what that month was
for me and
um yeah but it was beautiful it was
really really good
and it was intentional just y'all know
there was no like crisis or something
but it went away just um i just need a
break
so but i am very very grateful to be
here tonight
and uh it is a huge privilege to
get to introduce the great maggie
tilford
um yes she's amazing and she's going to
be speaking out you want to come on baby
and you know i was thinking about um how
to
kind of intro her and i mean obviously
there's a lot i could say
um just about what a special person she
is but i think in terms of how it
relates to this community
what i want to name is that probably
more than any other person here
she really embodies and expresses
our values our values here at the table
that were thoughtful
inclusive eclectic communal
and vulnerable and when i think
of maggie i just think of all of those
things
and man what a what a gift to have um
just someone like her in our midst and i
know i'm biased of course i am but
uh i really believe it and i know i mean
you all know her she is she's really
amazing so
um all right can i say a quick prayer
for you
that'd be okay lord jesus i thank you
for maggie
um just for who she is and i know you've
given her
a word for us tonight god and so
may your um capital w word
how may it come through her lowercase w
words lord may your spirit speak through
her
and so can we just open up ourselves to
what you want to say
god would you speak in the powerful
life-changing name of jesus i pray
amen
thanks
um i don't know about all of that
but i do know that i'm very excited to
be here with you guys
and um as someone who is like a chronic
fomo
struggler um it was great to be gone
with family and to reconnect and unplug
but i'm always
like ready to come back i'm not a big
fan of missing out so
i was like yup let's go back to church
it's time
so and being able to come back and on a
night where i get to share is like
super privilege so um thank you thank
you those of you who are online tonight
on the other side of that screen thank
you for joining us
and um i really do feel honored and
humbled to just be able to share a
little bit of my heart and
some of what i feel like i've been
learning in this last season
um from the holy spirit so um
i will say we originally
asked josh brock to speak tonight so i
am the backup
of the great josh brock who had to turn
us down because he
is on shift at the fire station but i
told
josh in a text last week what happens if
you turn us down and you don't do the
sermon
is i'm going to put you in the sermon
and now i get to talk about you
when you're not around so i titled
tonight's message the gift of blindness
and you'll see more why but
the best story that i could possibly
think of to just
start us off is a little anecdote from
the life of josh brock himself
um those of you who don't know josh
personally
you need to meet him you've i'm sure
seen him like either online or
on the stage here leading us in worship
when he's not on shift or when he's not
coaching his son's baseball he's a busy
guy you guys i don't know it's sort of
like you have to have a josh brock
sighting
you know he's just you never know when
he's going to show up there's josh look
at josh
his beautiful wife joe took that picture
and i just thought it was so fabulous
that we needed to put it on the screen
shout out to joe brock photography
everybody
but here's the deal
here's the deal josh is seriously he's
an inspiring person to be around he is
eternally optimistic he's just like
all all fun all the time it seems like i
mean i know that that's not true for
you know in reality but really and truly
josh is just a super fun
guy he is a seven on the enneagram and
for those of you who know what the
enneagram's like and know about sevens
that just means lifelong party baby like
and
that's what i that's just the vibe you
get around josh just like
chill kick back let's have fun
everyone's good
um and i he also with that comes this
gift
that you always see the glass as like
half full
or at least you want to always try and
see the glass as half full instead of
half empty
and it really is a skill that he has
truly honed throughout his life
sevens don't typically like to admit
when they're having like
negative feelings or they don't like to
sit with uncomfortable
emotions they're more likely to just be
like on to the next let's keep the party
going let's not stop so
when you're around josh um you know
there's a dark side of that and there's
a beautiful side but the beautiful side
is that they're really good at being
like this is not a bad thing this is an
opportunity for greatness
and i came to know that at a really deep
level
when um he was at our house a few months
back and we played a game called
stuff happens do you all know this game
it's like i think i have a picture of
the box this is
um that's the pg version there's
multiple
this one is called stuff happens
the other one is not stuff happens
okay but what it is is it's a deck of
cards
and each card has a life situation
written on it that would be an
inconvenience to you in some way shape
or form and it could be something
very minor like you know getting a paper
cut
on your tongue you know or it could be
something
super tragic like you walk into a hive
of bees and you're stung from head to
toe you know like
you don't know what card you're gonna
get dealt but your object
as a participant in the game is
whatever card is dealt to you you're
trying to place it
in a misery index that has been rated by
like psychiatrists and therapists
according to their research and their
you know interactions with people
through the years
of what is the potential
trauma or long-term hazard that this
could cause
someone and you're rating it on a scale
of 0
to 100. so you never know what cards
you're going to be dealt and this
particular night
it was josh's turn and he has a few
cards laying out on his table and he's
put them in his
what you call the lane of pain and you
know line them out
from least traumatic to worse traumatic
experiences
and when you get your next card on your
turn you try to figure out like
you're guessing what score it has like
okay well i know
if the paper cut was five you know what
i mean and then
the b stings was 72
then i'm going to guess that losing my
wallet on the subway
is a 34. you know what i mean and you're
trying to like
place it in the category of trauma
josh gets the card going blind
and i don't remember the exact number
i'll be honest with you
i do know this i know it was somewhere
between the teens and the twenties and
he put it literally his other cards if i
am if my memory and i've like asked his
wife and i've asked mindy and john like
i've pulled the audience to make sure
i'm not remembering this wrong but it
was somewhere between like
finding um your waiter's fingernail in
your bowl of soup
and losing your job
like it was we're we're talking about
losing the gift of sight and josh is
like
i think i'll write that at 23 and we're
all like sitting at the table like
what who are you and what happened to
you at birth like what is the matter
with you josh
and this is literally what he said he's
like guys some of the world's best
musicians were born blind think of
ray charles think of stevie wonder this
could be my ticket to fame
he's like if i go blind i could be world
famous playing my guitar someday
and like i remember joe looking at him
and joe's his wife
and she's like i don't think you
understand the way this game works
she's like you're supposed to play it
out to worst case scenario josh
but no josh is a seven so what does he
do he plays it out to
best case scenario like going blind
being world famous i can see this
working i mean like it was no surprise
later in the game he literally got a
card about
being held captive in a third world
prison for six months and josh rated it
somewhere in the 50s i'm like
does it get worse than that he's like i
thought the stories you would tell your
grandchildren
we're just like
josh was not good at that game i will
say his wife joe who is a six on the
enneagram actually killed us all that
night she
rocks at that game so i recommend
playing with josh and joe it's a really
good time
um but the reason i tell that story is
not just because we're talking about
blindness but because
in the on the subject of blindness and
as i've been
reading and learning about it over the
last month i feel like
perhaps all of us could take a lesson
from josh brock
because i think his interpretation of
what it means to go blind is actually
right in line with what jesus teaches in
the gospels so that's what we're going
to unpack tonight
and um i've been reading through the
book of john
at the beginning of the summer i started
and i'm only on chapter 10 guys
so it's been a slow haul but i love it i
love it love it love it and i keep
really reading the same stories
and i keep seeing this common theme that
has to do with vision
and eyesight and light and darkness and
the same words just keep you know like
when they just pop off the page and
you're like
here we go again we we just keep talking
about light darkness blindness
vision seeing like it's all there and
i've never noticed that before
but i think just because i've been
moving through the book chronologically
it's just really standing out to me and
so i want to frank we're going to spend
tonight
in john 9 and um before we dive in there
i just want to give you a little um
preview of coming attractions that i
feel like the writer of the book of john
gives us
in the very first chapter it opens up
talking about the word of god coming
into the world and the word of god being
christ
and this is how it describes him in
verse 9 and verse 4 and 5
of john chapter 1. verse 9 says the true
light
that gives light to every man was coming
into the world verse 4 says in him was
life
and that life was the light of men the
light
shines in the darkness but the darkness
has not
understood it so um
that concept like i said just keeps
sticking out to me over and over again
and fast forward one night i'm sitting
in our bedroom
brett goes to sleep a lot earlier than i
do because he's an old man
and so i literally am in my closet with
the door shut and the light on because
that's what i have to do when he beats
me to bed
so um or at least when i'm being
considerate that's what i do
um on this night i was being considerate
and i'm sitting in my closet
and i'm reading john 9 and it
literally was as if those verses that i
just read from john 1
it was like they said and now we're
going to take that theological concept
and we're just going to wrap it up in
human skin and we're just going to show
you a little
picture of what that's like so as we're
reading john 9
we can just keep that kind of as our
frame of reference
for those of you who might be triggered
by very long church services and pastors
who preach for a very long time this is
your trigger warning
john 9 is very long and so i apologize
but i could not cut any of it
we have to do the whole chapter guys
i'm gonna put on my best storytelling
verse though as we read it so feel free
to follow along on the screen
or open it up in your bible or just
watch me because i'll be as
animated as possible okay
as he went along he saw a man blind from
birth
and his disciples asked him rabbi who
has sinned
this man or his parents that he was born
blind
well neither this man nor his parent's
sin said jesus
this happened so that the work of god
might be displayed in his life
as long as it is day we must do the work
of him
who sent me night is coming do you hear
all the day night light
darkness night is coming when no one can
work
while i am in the world i am the light
of the world
and having said this he spit on the
ground
made some mud with his saliva and put it
on the man's eyes
as if that's totally normal they're like
who's sinned he's like no one the gift
of god will be shown in his life let's
do god's work
i'm like if i was that man i'd be like
excuse me i didn't even ask for this
but go he told him wash in the pool of
siloam
and this word means sint so the man went
and washed and came home
seeing his neighbors and those who had
formally seen him
begging asked isn't this the same man
who used to sit and beg on the side of
the street
and some claimed that he was but others
said
no i think he just looks like him but he
himself insisted
no i am that man
um where was i i
am that man okay
how then were your eyes open they
demanded and he replied
the man that they called jesus made some
mud put it on my eyes
he told me to go to siloam and wash so i
went and washed
and then i could see where is this man
they asked him
i don't know he said as if like um
just a reminder i was blind like i
actually don't know where he is i
couldn't see
um so they brought the pharisees
or they brought to the pharisees the man
who had been blind
and now the day on which jesus had made
the mud and opened the man's eyes
was of course a sabbath because jesus
loves to break all the rules
and therefore the pharisees also asked
him
how had he received his sight because
you know the pharisees like their job
is to make sure everyone is following
all the rules
so the issue here is not just did
someone receive their site but
how did they receive their site because
that's what we really need to be
worried about here not the fact that
someone literally went from being blind
to having vision
no let's skip over that and figure out
did anyone break a rule in the process
of making you see
because we're worried about that like
that's
the supreme issue here so
he says he put mud on my eyes
the man replied and i washed and now i
see
some of the pharisees said this man is
not from god
for he doesn't keep the sabbath but
others asked
well how can a sinner do such a
miraculous sign
miraculous miraculous signs so they were
divided
and finally they turned again to the
blind man
and said what do you have to say about
him it was your eyes that he opened
and the man replied he's a prophet
the jews did not believe that he had
been blind and had received his sight
until they sent for the man's parents
is this your son they asked is this the
one that you say was born blind
so how is it that now he can see
well we know he is our son the parents
answered and we know he was born blind
but how he can see now or who opened his
eyes we don't know
ask him he's of age he'll speak for
himself
his parents said this because they were
afraid of the jews for already the jews
had decided that
anyone who acknowledged that jesus was
the christ would be put out of the
synagogue
so that's why his parents said you know
he's of age ask him
a second time they summoned the man who
had been born blind
give glory to god by telling the truth
they said we
know that this man is a sinner and he
replied whether he is a sinner or not
i don't know one thing i do know i was
blind
and now i see then they asked him well
what did he do to you
how exactly did he open your eyes and he
answered
i've told you already and you did not
listen why do you want to hear it again
do you want to become his disciples too
which i love that is the snarkiest
response
i love that he's like listen i have
literally spelled this out for you three
times
and then you went and got my parents and
now you are asking me again
surely you're interested in following
him um which is just the insult of
insult for the pharisees
um they then they
hurled insults at him and said you are
this fellow's disciple
we're disciples of moses and we know
that god spoke to moses
but as for this fellow we don't even
know where he comes from
and the man answered now that is
remarkable
you don't know where he comes from but
he opened my
eyes we know that god doesn't listen to
sinners he listens to the godly man who
does his will
nobody has ever heard of opening the
eyes of a man born blind
if this man were not from god he could
do nothing and to this they replied
you were steeped in sin at birth how
dare you lecture us
and they threw him out which i just need
a pause right there to say
have you ever had a kid watch them like
go up to their dad and be like
dad we're hungry can we please have a
snack and the dad's like no you need to
wait for dinner
so then they walk over here and they're
like mom i'm so hungry
can i please have a snack and the mom's
like baby it's almost dinner time you
can't have a snack and then they're like
is there a grandma in the room like
[Music]
an aunt or an uncle is there someone
else that's what i feel like was
happening with the pharisees like
they're just gonna keep asking the same
questions
because they're not liking the answer
they're getting so they're just like
let me find another source on the issue
like maybe they will enlighten us with
some new information
and that is what i feel like we do even
as adults though
when there's a truth that is too hard to
swallow
we just keep asking the same questions
because we don't like the answer we're
getting and we cannot face it
so often when a truth challenges us or
threatens our current positioning on an
issue
or a topic or a relationship and that
truth is too hard for us to swallow
we are just exactly like the pharisees
we just keep checking for another source
on the issue
and we keep moving i've seen this happen
in relationships and i know
i mean in myself in my not good moments
this is true like if i
hurt someone's feelings i was feeling
really justified and then more
information comes forward where i'm like
oh god
this is bad i might have to apologize
i'm like
you know i actually think when i like
start writing my own story on the
narrative
actually second thought i think it might
have played out differently
and you just keep entertaining different
ideas
until you can land at something more
comfortable
something that doesn't cause you to
change anything
and that is what i feel like is
happening with the pharisees here
so to keep going verse 35
jesus heard that they had thrown the man
out
and when he found him which i just want
to say right there
that makes my heart happy like jesus
tracked what happened and he heard that
the guy was thrown out
and he goes and finds him bonus points
for jesus
um and when he found him he said
do you believe in the son of man who
is he sir the man asked tell me so that
i can believe in him
and jesus said you have now seen him
in fact he is the one speaking with you
the man says lord i believed
and he worshipped him and jesus said for
judgment i have come into this world
so that the blind will see and that
those who see
will become blind some pharisees who
were with him
heard what he said and so they
immediately asked
what are you saying are we blind too
and jesus said if you were blind
you would not be guilty of sin but now
that you claim you can see
your guilt remains if you were
blind you would not be guilty of sin
but now that you claim you can see your
guilt remains
do you hear a little josh brock attitude
there
a little bit of elevating blindness over
these people who feel like they see
perfectly clearly
when i read this that night in my closet
i'm sitting there and i really was so
struck between the eyes and let me tell
you why
i honestly at first i was struggling
with some feelings of
discomfort because
as much as i love a good underdog story
and it felt like at first i was feeling
very self-righteous like
yeah jesus get that man his vision and
look at those pharisees
stick it to the man like it just felt
good you know like they were getting put
in their place
finally and here's the old beggar on the
side of the road
who's now seeing and he's the one who
has the truth and these other people
who are getting to dictate what's right
and who's wrong and who's in and who's
out
are kind of getting told what for and i
loved that at first
but then the more i
sat with it i also noticed these
feelings of like
kind of a cringe factor happening and a
little bit of like
sadness for the pharisees and i think
that's because if i'm honest like i do
have bad days where i can relate to the
man born blind
but most of the time guys like let's
admit it
like i am a white able-bodied
straight good christian
woman raising her kids in the suburban
south
and most of the time that leaves me on
the side of privilege more often than
not
i can't really relate to this man born
blind i never begged a day in my life
the pharisees on the other side of the
fence
i can relate to that i actually know
exactly what it feels like to be really
justified in your position
i know what it feels like to not want
anyone to mess with what you have worked
so hard at building
and you're kind of just your goal is
just to maintain
the status quo because you know what the
status quo has really served you well
all these years and i would just
appreciate it
if everyone could stop questioning me or
trying to correct me or bring some new
insight into my life
that's going to make me question
everything that i've ever thought or
felt
and that is a very threatening position
to be in
so quite frankly i feel like if jesus
is challenging the pharisees then i'm
in that camp and when i read verses
and this is true throughout my life
anytime i read verses where jesus says
things like
similar to verse 39 because there's a
lot of places in the bible where you'll
hear
similar statements to this for judgment
i have come into this world
so that the blind will see and that
those who see will become blind
what i was hearing because i'm in the
position of someone who is more
privileged
and someone who feels very right in
their thinking
that is a direct like if he's judging
then he's judging me
and i don't like to be judged i mean no
one likes to be judged but
i don't like to be questioned on my
motives i don't like to be questioned on
the
opinions that i've come to you know
inherit or believe
and um i always
thought of that verse as sort of like
jesus
is just a little bit mean
i'm i'm like a real believer
in second and third and fourth chances
actually
to be very vulnerable my kids came to me
once and they were like i just don't
they were talking about one of their
friend's parents
i just don't like going to their house
and i was like why
and they're like because they're mean to
their kids
and i was like they are and they said
yes
and my daughter eve oh lord help us all
she looks at me and she's like
they don't even give second chances
which means mom you always give me a
second chance before i get in trouble
always
and i don't know what to do when people
don't let me try again before i get in
trouble
but i'm a big believer in like second
third fourth fifth chances like
partial progress is such good progress
like that's just
how i live my life i just want you know
i just want everyone to win at the end
of the day like can we all just win
let's all be on the winning category and
so when jesus says so that the blind
will see and that those who see will
become blind
i interpreted that as sort of like
a death sentence for the pharisees like
when it comes to the kingdom of god of
course not in the moment
but when it comes to spiritual things
they have now been eliminated like
they don't deserve it they think they
can see
so their punishment then is that now
now the tables are going to be reversed
and god's flipping everything on its
head and now
the people who were begging get to be in
the position of power
and the people who were in power now you
have to be the ones who are begging on
the side of the street
and that is how i interpreted it
honestly because i think i have a very
human way
of thinking of winning and losing in a
very black and white dichotomy
and i kind of thought that that's the
way jesus thought too
until i read the last verse and he's
saying
if you were blind you would not be
guilty of sin
as if being blind is actually a good
thing
so when jesus tells the pharisees
so that the blind will see and those who
see will become blind
it hit me and like i really did get
emotional sitting there
because i thought oh my gosh maybe he's
not condemning them
maybe he's throwing them a lifeline like
maybe instead of punishing them with
blindness
he's offering the gift of sight
and he's literally saying like for you
to ever really understand
life at its fullest you've got to
understand what it is to be blind
you've got to start there or you'll
never get to see things the way
i've designed them if you keep operating
in this very dualistic
black and white winter loser thing
you'll never get to
know the gift of god but if you can
understand what it is to be blind
and to be in need and to be in that
posture of
really trusting and being willing to be
led
then you are perfectly postured to
receive the gift of god
and that was so hopeful for me
like the thing that was hitting me was
what if
maybe even in his judgment he's saving
me
maybe even in the judgment of god
he is saving us not condemning us
but giving us the opportunity to see
and now you understand why like i
couldn't help but think of that story
with josh brock
because here's jesus being like but if
you were blind
think of the opportunities but really i
was hearing it with just such
fresh ears and fresh eyes and
and it was kind of turning everything on
its head while at the same time
sounding incredibly familiar
because if you grew up reading the bible
or if you know anything about the gospel
at all
we follow a savior who finds life out of
death
and who brings resurrection from a cross
and we follow a jesus who on the sermon
of the mount says
guess what it's those who are hungry who
are going to be satisfied
and it's those who are thirsty who are
going to receive
um you know the gift of righteousness
it's
those who are poor who get to inherit
the earth it's the meek
like he's always turning everything on
his head that's just christianity 101.
so for me as i read
this it was almost like well duh maggie
duh that's what it means to be a
christian
going blind is of course a good thing
like this is an opportunity to see but
my point tonight is just this
and this is just what i want to close
with i don't have like three steps or
i don't have three anything i just have
one thing
in the moments where you feel like you
have lost it all
maybe god is giving you the gift
of being able to start fresh
and receive real life for the first time
and maybe in the moments where you feel
like
everything's being turned on its head
maybe that is like your first
glimpse of the light that brings life to
all men
and at least speaking from my personal
experience
it's normally as the garment is becoming
unraveled
i feel like god clothes me in true
spirituality
and this i feel like is just an
invitation it's just a starting line
just to say that maybe we all need to
open ourselves
up to seeing things like our weakness
as an opportunity to know god's strength
and being able to see our the places
where we feel incapable
as actually the place where god meets us
the place where he reveals himself
the place where we become more in tune
with the way of jesus rather than
less in tune so it's not a judgment
it's an invitation
it's an invitation so i'm inviting you
guys to join me in that process of
redefining
redefining those places in our lives and
um i'm gonna stop there and if the
worship team wants to come up
i'm just going to say a prayer to close
us and
then we'll wrap up tonight's service
god i just thank you um
i thank you for the ways that you keep
rewriting the story
um over and over again and bringing
light into darkness bringing hope out of
situations
maybe we were interpreting them as a
punishment
or maybe
maybe there was something in our lives
that
it did feel hopeless or maybe it felt
like it was eliminating us from being
able
to be part of all the good things in
life
and i just i just ask that you might
give us
new vision god to
to really tap into those places and to
allow you
to put that mud on our eyes so that we
could
see for the first time truly clearly
and help us where we have judged things
as good or bad
and allow us instead to open ourselves
up to what you might have for us in the
process
so that we could be more like the man
who was blind and had
everything to gain rather than the
pharisees who thought they could see
and were so afraid of losing everything
so i just asked that we would lean more
into that posture
it's in your name that i pray amen
thank you maggie i just
um give you guys permission if you want
to just sit back during this song
and read the lyrics that are on the
screen and just let those soak in
and wherever you find yourself um
relating tonight to the story whether
it's
the pharisee or the blind man let these
words
um speak to you and let them open this
up to what god is doing in our heart
they tried to keep you in a tent
that could not keep you in a temple
or any of their idols
to see and understand
we cannot keep you in a church
we cannot keep you in a bible
it's just another idol
to box you in they could not
keep you in their walls we cannot keep
you in ours either
for you are so much greater
[Music]
who isn't like the lord
the maker of the heavens who dwells with
the poor he lifts them from
the ashes and sees them
among princes who
is like the lord
[Music]
we've tried to keep you in our tents
we've tried to keep you in our temples
we worshipped all our idols we want all
that to
end so we will find you in the streets
and we will find you in the prisons and
even in
our bibles and churches
who is like the lord
the maker of the heavens who dwells with
the poor and lifts them from
the ashes and seats them among princess
who is like the lord
[Music]
the glory
the glory of
who is like the lord
the maker of the
who lifts me from the ashes
and heals me from my blindness
who is like the lord
thank you maggie for that thank you
worship team
so glad you guys were here tonight what
a great message
what great things to take with us as we
go out from here and into our week
so much to think about pray on chew on
so
yeah i appreciate that maggie so much
what a great month we've had with all of
our guest speakers
so just to close and before you leave
if you're visiting with us tonight i'm
so glad you were here with us
please before you leave make sure to go
out to the table out there there are
little cards
just write down your name and contact
information we would love
to connect with you this week and get to
know you better and let you know a
little bit more about the table
there's a little box out there you can
put that card in if you're online
you can go on our website thetabletx.org
and you can contact us there you can
give on the website
find out more about our vision and
values also don't forget about
all the festivities coming up next
saturday and sunday i won't go into all
of them we'll have them on our facebook
page
and thirdly if you guys could all stand
up
i would love you love to send you out
into your week with this benediction
you are a child of god
this is true on your best day and it's
true
on your worst day it's true for those
that are standing or sitting around you
right now wherever you are
and it's true for those outside of this
building
so as you go into your week ahead with
it's yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and that desire to extend those same
gifts of unconditional love and grace
to everyone you come in contact with
this coming week be blessed
we hope to see you back here next sunday
at 11 am
lord the maker of the heavens
who deals with the poor
and lifts them from the ashes
seats
who is
you